[Musique]
à première vue rien ne distingue cette
bijouterie de n'importe quel autre
joaillerie à Toronto la différence c'est
qu'ici la plupart des diamants vendus
sont équitables ou Canadiens ce qui veut
dire qu'il réponde à certaines normes
environnementales et sociaux économiques
et bien que la Russie soit le plus
important producteur de diamant au monde
vous ne trouverez pas ici de diamant
russe une offre qui plait de plus en
plus à la clientèle surtout depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine il y a
certainement des clients qui viennent
nous voir qui disent je ne veux
absolument pas avoir des diamants Russie
avec la guerre ça a aidé les gens à
réaliser que les que les diamants sont
vraiment connectés à la politique et que
c'est très important de savoir où nos
matériaux viennent avec près de 30% des
exportations mondiales la Russie est le
plus important fournisseur de diamants
au monde la quasi-totalité de la
production on vient du géant minier
alrossa une entreprise détenue en partie
par l'Etat russe et dont les revenus
liés à la vente de diamants ont totalisé
plus de 4 milliards de dollars en 2021
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
des pays comme le Canada et les
États-Unis ont annoncé des sanctions
envers alrossa et son président Serge
Ivanov et certains des plus grands
bijoutiers du monde comme Stéphanie and
Co et Pandora ce sont engagés à ne plus
acheter de diamants russes une situation
qui pourrait avantager le Canada
troisième producteur au monde dont les
diamants sont considérés par plusieurs
comme plus responsables
qui se spécialise dans la vente de
diamants Canadiens depuis près de 15 ans
Satan d'ailleurs à une augmentation de
la demande pour les diamants canadiens
au cours des prochaines années il ajoute
que le Canada à ses doté d'outils comme
le Code de Conduite sur les diamants
canadiens pour garantir l'authenticité
de des diamant et leur permettre de se
démarquer sur le marché
cette expert souligne toutefois que les
diamants russes bénéficient toujours
d'importants déboucher puisque des pays
comme l'Inde et la Chine n'ont pas
imposées de sanctions contre la Russie
les diamants Canadiens peuvent coûter de
10 à 15 % plus cher que les autres
diamants sur le marché notamment en
raison des coûts liés aux mesures de
traçabilité pour garantir leur origine
on conseille donc au consommateurs
soucieux de l'origine de leur diamant de
demander ses garanties directement à
leur bijoutier il Sandra Williams
Toronto